he is the man of the hour in Baltimore
along with his quarterback and obviously
the Ravens are atop the AFC North after
taking care of business against the New
England Patriots handing them their
first loss of the season and a hundred
and fifteen rushing yards on Sunday
Night Football
he is Mark Ingram how are you mark I'm
good how are you
how'd that win feel it was a big win for
us it felt great why was it so big man
it was because it was the next one you
know it was the next one on the schedule
and obviously the Patriots coming to
town undefeated great team great coach
great quarterback great players for us
to go out there and have a complete team
win overcome some adversity overcome
some mistakes and just have a solid game
as a team I think that's something that
we with that we could be proud of so how
did you take it upon your shoulders to
lead the way in this game knowing that
you'd play such a crucial role mark I
just try to you know when my numbers
card when my assignment comes in and the
place card I just tried to execute
whatever my assignment is to the best of
my ability do my job do it at a high
level and do everything I can to help us
be victorious and have success and the
fact that it was the Patriots how much
did that add to it mark let's be honest
here come on everybody obviously you're
gonna get up to play the Patriots you
know they're the defending Super Bowl
champs they're undefeated coming into
your home on a Sunday night obviously
the motivation you know is there you
don't need to talk or say any words
everybody knows on the biggest days
against a great team so you got to bring
your best foot forward man against those
guys if you want to have a chance to win
looks like you were talking from from
jump from the first brush mark were you
yapping
were you talking no now we're talking I
already talked too much I'd be excited
sometimes and you know might you know
that my emotions come out but I wouldn't
talking to anyone specifically it's just
[Applause]
I dunno and Lamar Jackson seems to be
getting better and better there was a
little bit of a dip after your your to a
know start what what has his development
been from your perspective you know
obviously best you're standing right
next to him most of the time you're in
the huddle with him
what what has it been like for your
perspective with Lamar Jackson's
development here then it's just going to
continue to improve that way the same
way he's improving the same way he's
developing it's just going to continue
to get better he's gonna team to get
more comfortable he's gonna continue to
know what defenses are trying to how to
defend him
what would the different looks being
confident our offense the different
checks we have he's just growing more
and more on the field a great dude off
the field he's gonna continue to have
this improvement he's gonna continue to
have those tries you know the more he
plays more he has successes the more he
has failures he's gonna learn from them
and get better you got an example of
what he's done
say maybe on Sunday night that he either
I wouldn't say struggled but definitely
didn't do as readily or a second nature
say week one I just think he's just
growing man I think he's just learning
how defenses are trying to corral him
and defend him obviously he knew when
the the Patriots were bringing cover
zero he knew he had you know improvise
get the ball out of his hand quickly we
didn't make any mistakes
he's running good getting down not
taking huge hits he's he's just doing
everything the way we want him to man so
obviously we got to continue improving T
to get better there's some throws he
wish he could have had back in that game
but um yeah man even through all that
stuff we still able to have a great game
come out with a win Mark Ingram Ravens
running back here on the Rich Eisen
shows they get set to take on the
Cincinnati Bengals after taking care of
business against the Patriots on Sunday
Night Football so let me hit you with
the I guess conventional wisdom and some
people's minds not not here not in this
position as you know I said that this
was your division to lose back in July
so this is not me and I'm not pulling
one of those things in the media where
I'm saying other people are saying and I
believe it too so all that said that I'm
hearing all in various parts that your
offense is not sustainable that in
January or February that this offense
will will not be able to work because of
how it relies on the run and not as much
of the past your thoughts marketing room
why wouldn't it just why wouldn't it be
sustainable and the plasterer supposed
to be physically
to run the ball weather permits you know
why wouldn't it be sustainable
you know everybody's these experts but
you know they're sitting you know
elsewhere they're not in this building
they don't know what we're about they
don't know the guys we have don't know
the work we put in attention to detail
that we look at when defenses are trying
to defend us and the different looks
that they fish on we think it's
sustainable and that's to be seen so we
will see we shall see we and we look to
prove the doubters wrong well I guess
and and that puts it squarely on number
eight shoulders that that that's not all
on his shoulders man it's all of us we
all have to have his back we all have to
make his job easier we all have to make
his job you know as easy as possible for
him everybody around them all ten people
people running in and out the huddle we
have to execute know our assignment and
perform it to the high level so we can
make his job easy and make the plays
that we know you can on occasion mark if
you peaked at the standings in the NFC
South or the exploits of your former
team I don't yeah I know I know they
hold it down down there and NFC South I
know they're getting it right they they
got the team man they've been there two
years in a row I know what it takes so
it doesn't surprise me what they got
going on and I'm wondering what you
think of Bridgewater I don't think he
gets nearly enough attention Bridgewater
is that dude you hear me you understand
me
Teddy Bridgewater Teddy ice-water as I
call him you feel me he went in there
back behind the wall you know I mean
Drew Brees is out you think the Saints
are you know getting derailed for their
season he comes in goes five and OH
leaves that team and got him in great
position and going into second half of
the season so I'm happy for Teddy
ice-water did his pain man he's a beast
I love him well part of the reason why I
bring it up is just I think your
reaction to just me even bringing it up
is part of the reason why I wanted to
bring it up because of how how popular
he is not just in the locker room but
league-wide as to what happened to him
how he got drafted into the league in
how he had an opportunity that was
robbed from him because of the injury
gods and what he was able to do this
year to me is one of the stories of the
year that will obviously get lost
because if he's not starting in the
second half of the season that's why I
wanted to bring it up to you mark you
know yeah I agree with you man
just like you said this complete story
obviously him getting drafted on being
up there doing well in Minnesota and
then have another you know the Freak
knee accident
some people never come back from that
and for the fact that him he's just so
mentally tough mentally strong so into
himself to be comfortable rehab and
getting back 200% being confident not
taking some other job around the league
in the offseason but staying in New
Orleans it paid off for him and just as
mindset how he cares about people how he
spreads love his work in the community
all that being said with with his
ability to play at a high level as
quarterback I think you know he's just a
fan favor and you can't help but but to
root for a man like that plus one I'm
with you on that Marc hearing a few more
minutes left with the Ravens running
back and of course former August former
you know you once the Crimson Tide
always a Crimson Tide what's gonna
happen this weekend what is it man we do
this every year man you always want to
do this LSU Alabama LSU is gonna beat us
somehow they got this new systems new
coast its new quarterback these new
playmakers it happens every year man
belma's is gonna hold it down we're
gonna do we do we gonna play Bama
football you're gonna have to come in
here play for 60 minutes play physical
you're gonna have to play smarter than
us
we just gonna play Bama football and we
will prevail we will prevail nano time
baby I do have to though play a little
devil's advocate here you say it happens
all the time it happens etc and it's and
each time the result is Alabama's you
have to at least admit nobody's looked
like Burrell has for LSU I mean the kids
got 30 touchdowns which sometimes if you
put a couple or three seasons together
LSU quarterbacks you won't get to that
and yet he's got that coming into this
game he's only missed on say 55 of his
passes this year kids pretty darn good
though mark yeah yeah man I respect him
I respect LSU and their program I
respect them our spec Burroughs has a
quarterback he's balling out of control
for LSU but listen man he hasn't seen
Belma yet he hasn't seen coach saving
yet we're gonna be flying around we
gonna have something for him to just be
able to slow him down a little bit you
know I mean we know he's gonna make his
place we know that defense is tough they
gonna make they plays but we just got to
make more plays than they do so at the
end of the day I think that's will be
do man we go bend but not break they
gonna make some plays but we gonna make
more plays the thing that's amazing is
our I'm already hearing or at least my
producer Chris Brockman across the way
here has been seeing all these mock
drafts that has Joe above tour in the
NFL Draft
what makes two is so special you
obviously know what a quarterback can do
it the next level so you give you the
floor on this one I think he just has
the complete package as a quarterback
knowing coverages going through his
route progressions knowing if you're
taking this primary away he knows where
his number to it he knows where his
check now that he can improvise with his
legs he's not looking to run he's
looking to improvise and buy himself
time to throw down the field
so just his knowledge of an offense how
he commands the huddle his composure in
the huddle his ability to make every
throw deep passes deep deep curls
comebacks you know run our PL system I
think his just knowledge of at the
quarterback position is super high
compared to most other college
quarterbacks all right and who would be
your vote right now for the husband if
you had if you're forced to give one
right now I had to give it right no good
thing about it I don't have to give it
right that's not that's not the answer I
I can't accept that
no I mean I ask you who's you're having
to pick if I give you my vote you
handled it there's three ways for you to
handle that one was saying I'll answer
the question two is saying I don't have
to answer the question in 3 now this is
why you're a savvy veteran you turn the
tables on me you know what I would I
would kind of have to give it right now
man
what I I kind of didn't like man no I
know I kind of do like what your former
Crimson Tide and Jalen Hertz is done for
a whoa yeah he'd been ballin well one
loss no they got a loss right but see
I'm on that's what I think stinks about
college football these days is you get a
loss and you automatically stink so I
got it what look at what Trevor Lawrence
is doing or I got to give it to Justin
fields or what you know
I mean III look at the the totality of
what Jalen Hertz did in Oklahoma you
talked about Teddy Bridgewater earlier
on in this and it's sticking with it and
not taking what you would say is the
easy way out yeah he stuck with it he
got his opportunity with a woman I
understand Oklahoma's turned out the
last two Heisman Trophy winners and I
get it but he's what he's done and then
he wins he puts up six hundred yards of
offense and goes in the weight room I
think it shows leadership ability in his
own locker room and and he damn near got
to come back in Kansas State that's why
I'm saying that listen I'm with you
1,000% on that I'm a Jalen Hurd's fan
how he handles his situation that Belma
you know sitting down you know letting
to a start to ends up getting injured he
comes in and repays the favor that tool
blessed him with the year before so I'm
with you a million percent Jalen does
deserve a Heisman Trophy voting
specially for how he's been playing and
been dominating the big 12 all year I
don't think it's gonna slow down but um
I'm with you on that man I'm a big
general hearse fan you know that roll
tide till I died I watch Oklahoma every
Saturday just to see what my dog jaylen
doing I'm a big fan of Jalen so I'm
gonna agree with you on that one that
says that said if LSU wins this weekend
I might have to change my vote we still
got a lot of games left a lot of tulle
coming up here left you know I mean so
mark you take care Congrats on that big
win Sunday night we'll check with you
down the road all right thank you right
back at you that's Mark Ingram one of my
favorites at Mark Ingram 21 on both
Twitter and Instagram right here in the
Rich Eisen show for more of the Rich
Eisen show tune - audience Channel 239
under red TV for free on BR Live or
download the Rich Eisen show app